So a whole bunch of very incriminating emails
have leaked, which show that the white house
and really everybody around president Donald
Trump knew all along that the goal of withholding
aid from Ukraine was to get them to do the
thing he wants to do to get him that deliverable,
which is these public announcements about
investigations into Joe and Hunter Biden for
the purposes of smearing the Bidens and helping
Donald Trump in 2020 and it's almost anticlimactic
to report this to you because anybody who
had been following the story, uh, with, with
some level of closeness and has been following
Donald Trump for three years or longer would
understand that that's exactly how it went
down.
And these are what can potentially be called
smoking gun emails with regards to what took
place.
The Washington post is now reporting that
hundreds of documents have turned up, which
show that after the fact, after the decision
was made to withhold the aid from Ukraine,
everybody at the white house was scrambling
trying to come up with some explanation, a
false explanation of course, an explanation
other than the real one for why the hundreds
of millions of dollars in aid were being withheld
from Ukraine.
We of course know that it was because Donald
Trump wanted to use that money as a way to
get Ukraine to smear Joe Biden.
So let's back it up just a little bit here.
One of the defenses that we're hearing from
Trumpist is, listen, everything's fine because
eventually Trump gave Ukraine the aid.
Now at face value, this is a worthless defense
because it implies that trying to commit a
crime isn't a problem as long as you fail
to commit it, which is ridiculous.
Apply that same logic to any other situation.
It doesn't make any sense.
But even more absurd is that the aid was released
when Adam Schiff sent a letter saying, Hey,
a whistleblower is telling us that you're
holding the aid hostage for a smear campaign
against Joe Biden.
And then low and behold, the aid is then released
to Ukraine.
And that is that action is now pointed to
to say, Hey, you know, we eventually gave
him the aid so there's nothing to see here.
But we now have the emails and they expose
that not only did people like Donald Trump's
chief of staff, Mick Mulvaney know exactly
what Donald Trump was doing.
They were worried it was not even legal back
in August.
Remember that the infamous phone call between
Donald Trump and president Zelenskyi of Ukraine
was on July 25 very close to in August Mulvaney
knowing that the aide had been withheld as
the director of the office of management and
budget, OMB for an update on the legal rationale
for withholding aid and how much longer can
we withhold the aid because Mulvaney knew
why it was being withheld and he suspected
he feared that it could be legally problematic.
Emails were then turned up between OMB and
the state department, the state department
officials corresponding about this with OMB
also were saying, well, hold on a second,
withholding.
This might be against the law.
The funds are congressionally approved and
now they are being withheld for what they
of course suspected were political reasons.
What is Trump doing wire?
How long can this go on?
Is this even legal?
So ultimately we have the same story from
all fronts.
The whistleblower says Trump is holding up
eight or was holding up aide to get Ukraine
to smear Biden.
It was a form of bribery.
Extortion.
Trump then goes on Fox and friends.
And in not so many words says, yeah, I told
him to investigate corruption, which is of
course code for smear the Bidens publicly
and why should we give them money anyway,
linking the investigation and the money publicly
for the first time.
As we told you yesterday, without even realizing
it, that story overnight, 350,000 views on
YouTube generating a lot of interest as it
should.
Then we heard from the impeachment witnesses
last week and the week before Gordon Sunland
sang, there was a quid pro quo.
Uh, and I suspect that there were actually
two, a quid pro quos quids pro quo, uh, more
witnesses last week, adding fuel to the fire.
Everybody knew this may be, as I read on Twitter,
this may be the most meticulously and extensively
documented presidential bribery extortion
scheme that we have ever seen.
And yet as we get to the other end of it,
in all likelihood, and it pains me to say
this, and I know people get mad because they
say, I'm conceding, I'm not conceding.
I'm simply, uh, analyzing that in all likelihood,
the Republicans in the Senate are going to
let Donald Trump remain in office and will
cheer at least publicly behind closed doors.
Who knows?
They will at least publicly cheer the reelection
of Donald Trump if, if, if it indeed happens.
Despite everything that every day we are learning,
every day we learn enough that by itself what
we learned on that day would be a nonstop
scandal under Barack Obama.
And yet Republicans and mostly Fox news and
other right wing media defend the president,
make excuses, stand aside.
They are all enablers
for what
is going on here.